IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE"
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNLEASHING ON
DEMOCRATS AND PUMMELING
JOE BIDEN DURING A FIERY
CAMPAIGN RALLY.
IT WAS HIS FIRST SINCE THE
DEMOCRATS LAUNCH THEIR INQUIRY.
THE PRESIDENT WASTED NO TIME
GOING ON THE ATTACK.
>> President Trump: DEMOCRATS
ARE ON A CRUSADE TO DESTROY OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THE WRETCHED WASHINGTON SWAMP
HAS BEEN TRYING TO NULLIFY THE
RESULTS OF A TRULY GREAT AND
DEMOCRATIC COLLECTION.
THEY WANT TO ERASE YOUR VOTE
LIKE IT NEVER EXISTED.
THEY WANT TO ERASE YOUR VOICE,
THEY WANT TO ERASE YOUR FUTURE.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T WIN THE
2020 ELECTION, SO THEY ARE
PURSUING THE INSANE IMPEACHMENT
WITCH HUNT.
>> Jesse: TRUMP ALSO HOARDING
IT ON JOE BIDEN AT HIS SON
HUNTER, MAKING THEIR SHADY
UKRAINE DEALINGS ATOP CAMPAIGN
TARGET.
>> President Trump: WHERE IS
HUNTER?
FELLOWS, I HAVE AN IDEA FOR A
NEW T-SHIRT.
I LOVE THE COPS.
BUT LET'S DO ANOTHER T-SHIRT.
WHERE'S HUNTER?
HUNTER, YOU'RE A LOSER.
WHY DID YOU GET $1.5 BILLION.
YOUR FATHER WAS NEVER CONSIDERED
SMART.
HE WAS NEVER CONSIDERED A GOOD
SENATOR.
HE WAS ONLY A GOOD
VICE PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTOOD HOW TO KISS
BARACK OBAMA WAS ASS.
THE BIDENS GOT
RICH AND THAT SUBSTANTIATED.
AMERICA GOT ROBBED.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
SLEEPY JOE AND HIS FRIENDS SOLD
OUT AMERICA.
>> Jesse: IT'S A TOUGH LINE OF
ATTACK, JUAN.
THE BIDENS GOT RICH.
AMERICA GOT ROBBED.
BY THE WAY, WHERE'S HUNTER?
>> Juan: LET ME JUST SAY I'M
SO HEARTBROKEN FOR AMERICA THAT
THAT IS THE PRESIDENT AND THAT'S
WHAT HE TALKS.
THAT'S THE WAY HE TALKS ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE HIS POLITICAL
RIVALS.
WE COULD DO THE JOURNALISTIC
THING AND SAY SO MUCH OF THIS IS
TRUMP'S UNSUBSTANTIATED CHARGES.
HE JUST WANTS TO THROW DIRT AT
SOMEBODY.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING THAT'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IN FRONT OF OUR KIDS TALKING
ABOUT THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT,
WHETHER YOU LIKE HIM OR NOT.
I WON'T REPEAT WHAT HE JUST SAI
SAID.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
AT SOME POINT WITH TRUMP, YOU
SAY TRUMP IS SO ENTERTAINING.
TRUMP IS GOING TO BE FUNNY OR
IT'S LIKE A SCHOOLYARD KID.
BUT IN THAT MOMENT, ALL RIGHT,
THE SECOND POINT, JESSE.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR FROM
THAT ATTACK LAST NIGHT THAT
THERE'S ONLY ONE DEMOCRAT THAT
HE IS CONCERNED WITH AND THAT IS
JOE BIDEN.
HE DOESN'T ATTACK
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS BEEN DOING
WELL IN THE POLLS.
DOESN'T ATTACK BERNIE SANDERS,
WHO DOES WELL IN THE POLLS.
BOTH HAVE DONE BETTER THAN BIDEN
IN TERMS OF FUND-RAISING THE
LAST QUARTER BUT HIS ACTIONS AND
WORDS, EVERYTHING FROM UKRAINE
AND THOSE UNSUBSTANTIATED
THEORIES TO THIS, SHOW THAT HE'S
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT JOE BIDEN
AND THIS WEEK IN THE FOX POLL,
OTHER POLLS AS WELL, JOE BIDEN
BEATING HIM HANDILY.
THIS WEEK WE ALSO HAD
RUDY GIULIANI'S PALS GOING TO
UKRAINE OR IT -- BEING.
PAID BY SOMEBODY TO TRY TO
INFLUENCE AMERICAN POLICY.
AGAIN, THEY WERE GOING AFTER
DIRT ON JOE BIDEN WHEN JOE BIDEN
AND THE SON OF BEEN FOUND TO BE
GUILTY OF ZERO.
>> Jesse: OKAY, JUAN.
VERY DARK AND GLOOMY ANALYSIS.
GREG, LET'S GO TO YOU FOR SOME
MORE SPUNK.
>> Greg: BIG SURPRISE, I DON'T
FEEL THE SAME WAY JUAN DOES.
I FIND IT INTERESTING WHEN
PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED BY
DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS THREE YEARS, OKAY?
IT'S A TRUMP RALLY.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET OVER IT.
YOU ARE LIKE THE GUY WHO OPENS
UP THE FRIDGE, KNOWS THAT THE
MILK IS SOUR AND YOU STILL SNIFF
IT.
YOU GO OH, MY GOD.
THE MILK IS SOUR.
THAT IS WHAT TRUMP IS.
YOU ACT LIKE THIS IS NEW IN
GENERAL.
THIS IS HOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT PEOPLE PRIVATELY,
HAVE DEMEANED US, HOW ACADEMIA,
ENTERTAINMENT.
TALKED ABOUT AMERICA.
THIS IS -- HE IS JUST TAKING
WHAT'S INSIDE AND TAKING IT
OUTSIDE.
SOMEBODY SMARTER THAN ME, THEY
LOOK AT THIS AND GO MY GOD.
THE NOON IS "THIS ISN'T NORMAL."
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT ISN'T NORMAL.
THAT'S WHY HE WON.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE TYPICAL
POLITICIAN.
YOU CAN HATE HIM.
YOU CAN HATE HIM EVERYTHING WILL
DIE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE.
BY THE WAY, YOU'VE GOT TO LOOK
AT THE ENERGY OF THAT RALLY AND
YOU GOT TO WONDER IF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY THINKING
STRAIGHT ABOUT THIS IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT THE LEFT ALWAYS WANTED,
THEY ALWAYS WANTED A
REVOLUTIONARY.
THEIR AMERICAN VERSION OF FIDEL
CASTRO, THEIR AMERICAN VERSION
OF CHE, THEY WANTED THAT.
HOW HILARIOUS IS IT THAT THE
REVOLUTIONARY IS A REPUBLICAN
TALK SHOW HOST.
THERE IMPEACHMENT IS GOING TO
TURN TRUMP INTO A REVOLUTIONARY
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN A POSITIVE
WAY THAT WILL CREATE A MOVEMENT.
THEY'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP
TRUMP WHEN YOU SEE THE ENERGY
THAT HE HAS AND THEN YOU COMPARE
IT TO BIDEN AT THE TOWN HALL ON
CNN.
YOU HAVE TRUMP TALKING CLEARLY,
SAYING EXACTLY WHAT HE'S
THINKING.
YOU SEE BIDEN SOUNDING LIKE HE
IS READING FROM A
"READER'S DIGEST" MAGAZINE FIVE
YEARS AGO THAT HE FOUND ON THE
TRAIN.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF ENERGY AND
CHARISMA LAST NIGHT.
HE WENT AFTER LISA PAGE AND
PETER STRZOK IN AN INTERESTING
FORAY.
LET'S LISTEN AND KATIE CAN
REACT.
>> President Trump:
PETER STRZOK.
[BOOS]
HE AND HIS LOVER, LISA PAGE.
I LOVE YOU, PETER.
I LOVE YOU TOO, LISA.
LISA, LISA.
OH, GOD.
I LOVE YOU, LISA.
IF SHE DOESN'T WIN, LISA, WE'VE
GOT AN INSURANCE POLICY, LISA.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF TARGETS.
>> Katie: NOT TOTALLY ACCURATE
DEPICTION OF THE TEXT THE TEXT
MESSAGES.
IN TERMS OF THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS DEMEANOR AND ATTITUDE.
ONE THING HE HAS IS HE'S
COMPLETELY SECURE WITH WHO HE
IS.
HE DOESN'T CARE WHAT HE SAYS.
DEMOCRATS ON THE OTHER HAND HAD
A VERY HARD TIME FINDING THEIR
OWN PLATFORM.
THEY HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
DEFENDING THEIR POSITIONS WHICH
IS WHY ELIZABETH WARREN HAS
CHANGED HER SO MANY TIMES AND SO
WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WITH ONE PERSON,
OF COURSE TRUMP IS GOING AFTER
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HE STILL IS
THE FRONT RUNNER.
HE WANTS TO KNOCK HIM OUT TO GET
TO ELIZABETH WARREN BECAUSE THE
COUNTRY SEES HER AS TOO FAR
LEFT.
THE ENERGY HE HAS IN A PLACE
LIKE MINNESOTA WHICH IS
GENERALLY A BLUE STATE WITH
20,000 PLUS PEOPLE WAITING IN
LINE IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR DEMOCRATS TO
COMPETE WITH IN STATES THAT
DON'T WANT TO BE DEFENDING
WITHOUT THE AMOUNT OF CASH ON
HAND AS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN HAS.
>> Jesse: THEY GOT A LOT OF
DATA LAST NIGHT FROM THE HUGE
CROWD AND THEY'RE GOING TO
HARVEST IT AND FUND-RAISING
TURNED THEM OUT.
>> Dana: THEY HAVE A MUCH
BETTER CHANCE OF FLIPPING
MINNESOTA THAN OTHER STATES LIKE
NEVADA, ALTHOUGH NEW HAMPSHIRE I
THINK STILL IN THEIR SITES.
NEW MEXICO MAY BE OUT OF REACH.
EVERYWHERE THEY GO, THEY GET
THIS DATA.
SOME COVERAGE SAYS IT WAS OFF
SCRIPT.
NO, THIS IS THE SCRIPT.
THIS IS IT.
MY FEELINGS ON THIS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY TO
CALL SOMEONE SON A LOSER.
YOU CAN QUESTION WHETHER THEY
WERE PEDDLING INFLUENCE AND
WHETHER THAT WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
I THINK IT'S A PRETTY STRONG
ARGUMENT.
THE BIDEN PILOTS ARE COMPLAINING
THAT THE DNC ISN'T DEFENDING
THEM ENOUGH.
THE DNC IS LIKE YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO DEFEND YOURSELVES.
THEY KNOW IT'S COMING AND THEY
ARE NOT ABLE TO GET OFF THE BACK
FOOT.
HOWEVER, EVEN WITH ALL OF THIS
IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS, BIDEN
IS STILL DOING PREWELL ACROSS
THE BOARD.
HE HAS STAYING POWER AND MAY BE
WHEN PEOPLE SAY WHAT DOESN'T
MATTER WHEN IT COMES TO TRUMP,
MAY BE DOESN'T MATTER AND IT
BIDEN.
>> Greg: I HATE TO USE THE
PHRASE BAKED INTO THE CAKE
BECAUSE I HATE THAT PHRASE BUT
WITH TRUMP, HIS PERSONALITY IS
BAKED INTO THE CAKE AND BIDEN'S
FOIBLES.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT'S WRONG
WITH BIDEN.
THEY MIGHT JUST HAVE TO BITE THE
BULLET ON THAT ONE.
>> Juan: BECAUSE.
>> Greg: THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: THEY HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION THAT THE LEFT IS
UNIFIED ON THE POINT OF BEATING
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: AND GETTING RID OF
BIDEN.
>> Juan: OF DON'T THINK THAT'S
TRUE.
I THINK DANA'S POINT IS WELL
TAKEN.
THE KIND OF NARRATIVE POINT IS
BEEN WARREN'S GAINING AND BIDEN
IS FADING BUT THE NUMBERS
INDICATE HER GAINS ARE NOT
COMING FROM BIDEN.
BIDEN REMAINS ON TOP.
>> Katie: IF YOU TAKE
BERNIE SANDERS OUT OF THE
POLLING AT HIS HARLEM VOTERS TO
ELIZABETH WARREN, THEY ARE NOT
ALL GOING TO VOTE FOR HER.
IT LEAPFROGGED OVER JOE BIDEN'S
NUMBERS AND YOU HAVE TO QUESTION
WHY THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN CONTINUES
TO SAY WE DON'T HAVE TO WIN
IOWA.
WE DON'T HAVE TO WIN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
MAYBE WERE NOT GOING TO TRY AND
THOUGH STATES AND THERE'S A
QUESTION IF JOE BIDEN KEEP
LASHING OUT AT THE MEETING,
WHERE IS THE DOUBLE STANDARD ON
THAT.
TRUMP SAYS STUFF ABOUT THE
MEDIAN HE'S ACCUSED OF ALL THESE
THINGS BUT JOE BIDEN IS SENDING
ME LETTERS TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND TELLING
THEM TO BACK OFF ON ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS FAMILY HAD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> Katie: HE DIDN'T -- YES, HE
DID.
>> Juan: PETER SCHWEIZER HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN MAKING
ALLEGATIONS.
>> Katie: HE WENT OFF ON A
REPORTER FOR HAVING --
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT MEDIA
COVERAGE, NOT A GOOD THING.